the democrats do not stand for defunding
police
some might say that the other party was
for defunding the police i'll let others
say that but
that's a piece what in the actual f like
seriously
remember this was their agenda and now
they have to run away from their own
agenda
the democrats are in a bit of trouble so
here's the thing
they're pushing forward with this
radical agenda in the military in every
area of american life
actually and this stuff is not popular
for some reason democrats seem to think
that twitter is real
now there's a study that came out from
pew research that i think is quite
important on this topic
this study came out october of 2020 and
what it showed
is that basically twitter is dominated
by democrats what they found is that
most us adults on twitter post only
rarely but a small share of highly
active users most of whom are democrats
produce the vast majority of tweets
the pew research center found that just
10 of users
produced 92 percent of all tweets from
us adults since last november so it's an
echo chamber right
between the 10 of users producing 92
percent of the tweets
69 of these highly prolific users
identify as democrats or democratic
leaning independents what this means
is that number one the platform has a
larger share of democrats than
republicans number two
because it's an echo chamber in which
the most powerful people are democrats
and the most frequent tweeters are
democrats
it's easier to ratio a republican than a
democrat and it's easier to get tons of
retweets if you're a democrat than a
republican
and this leads people into a belief that
the democratic wild progressive agenda
is significantly more popular than it is
it simply is not a good proof of this
david french pointed this out and it's a
great point
andrew yang had nearly 2 million twitter
followers during the new york mayoral
race eric adams had 14 thousand
eric adams just skunked and riang
because the real world is not twitter
and the same thing was true in bernie
sanders versus joe bidenville twitter is
not the real world yet
because that is the source of news and
people are inevitably biased by the news
that they consume
people on the left viewing twitter as
the real world as opposed to an echo
chamber
tend to think that their policies are
much more popular than they are then
they enact those policies and it turns
out the policies suck
they're nowhere is this truer than when
it comes to policing and crime
so the democrats are about to get their
asses handed them in 202 on the issue of
crime
the crime rates in the united states
have skyrocketed they'd already started
skyrocketing
before the riots in 2020 they actually
started skyrocketing in 2014 2015 with
the ferguson riots
and then it calmed down a little bit and
then in 2020 they just exploded you're
seeing the murder rates in virtually
every major metropolitan area dominated
by democrats
just unbelievable numbers unbelievable
numbers
and members of the police forces are
pointing this out so for example the
lapd police chief
he said you know we were beating back
crime we're doing a pretty good job of
it and now that's all
gone we've led the country in crime
reduction over this past decade we've
shown that cops count for police matter
that community engagement is the leading
aspect of crime
prevention and that crime reduction also
is tiered that is tied to
effective policing identifying those
that are involved in the violence
bringing them before the justice system
and holding them accountable all of that
in this last year
has been terribly and devastating
devastatingly impacted
okay so the reality of course is that
crime in los angeles is up wildly
year over year the the murder rate is up
like 25
and that is not a great shock we've seen
the same thing in every major american
city so the democrats have been faced
with a simple reality
and that is that their preferred
policies with regard to the cops blaming
the cops for all racial disparities
in crime statistics suggesting that
getting rid of the cops is the solution
to all of this blaming systemic racism
none of this is actually solving the
problem
of actual crime in which people get hurt
or killed
so they've come up with a few different
strategies one is to deny there is a
problem
so for example you have dc mayor mural
bowser whose big
who's whose most important contribution
to fighting crime
was painting a giant black lives matter
mural on the streets of washington dc
and then watching as many of her
citizens just got shot in the streets
she went on in front of the senate
and she claims that there was only one
night of rioting in dc last summer which
is weird because there are literally
millions of people who remember dc being
curfew for like a week
do you have a property damage estimate
from the summer riots
i'm i'm glad to hear you say that you
are opposed to
riotous behavior whether it happened on
16th street or here
matt and could you could you could you
answer the question do you have an
estimate of the property damage during
the summer riots i know that we had
one night of um rioting in the district
do you know do you know how many people
do you know how many people were
arrested for the summer riots
uh we've had dozens of people arrested
over the last year
okay so um pretty impressive denial that
anything went wrong in washington d.c
under her auspices even though
again i know lots of people who are
living in washington dc who are
basically bunkered down in their
apartment
for a week on end while people ran
roughshod through the city
hey that's one strategy one strategy
sets to downplay this you saw this from
mayor lori lightfoot yesterday she did
the same exact thing in chicago she said
no no crime is actually down
from last year when it was up
dramatically so really well done
the the other strategy is to deny the
democrats are behind you sort of defund
undercut the police
routine in the first place so this is
pushed by senator mazie hirono
legitimately the stupidest member of the
united states senate from hawaii
suggesting that democrats don't stand
for defunding the police oh interesting
because
it seems like um kind of your vice
president was calling to bail out
rioters
last year and also joe biden suggested
shifting funding away from the cops and
toward social workers
and also there's been an attempt by the
biden doj to crack down on police
departments across the country but don't
worry they're not anti-cop
the democrats do not stand for defunding
police
the police have a major role to play
especially
community policing and reducing the
incidence of violence and crime in our
communities but
it is a multi-faceted issue
and concerns and that's how we should
approach it it is not
all about let's just get tough on crime
it's not about we'll just get tough on
crimes it's not about defunding the
police but also it's not about getting
tough on crime also we're not against
defunding the police except for you know
those of us who are like india walton
who just
won the buffalo mayoral primary democrat
explaining that um their plan is to
shift money away from the cops and put
it toward
community development so this is going
well
my plan is to put our resources into
community into neighborhoods and
govern in a deeply democratic way that
the people who are governed have
say over the decision-making process and
how resources are deployed in our
community hmm
so yeah they're not against defending
the police except when they're
completely free funding the police but
here's the good news they can also blame
republicans for defunding the police
that's literally what jen saki tried to
do
she literally i mean this is so the the
gall of this is
pretty rich so you have an entire
democratic party that has embraced the
notion that systemic racism and american
policing
is what ails the united states in terms
of both race relations and crime
and then you have gensake get up there
and say oh yeah and it's republicans who
want to defund the police
yeah lady i mean my god not all of us
are double-digit iqs here part of his
announcement is also
ensuring their specific guidance to
communities across the country to ensure
that they have funding to get
more community police around the country
something that was supported by
the american jobs plan that was
supported that was voted into law by
democrats just a couple of months ago
some might say that
the other party was for defunding the
police i'll let others say that but
that's a piece you see
it's cute because in the infrastructure
package there was two trillion dollars
there's like five bucks for the cops and
then they voted against it so that they
hit the
haha i mean it's unbelievable the
gaslighting so remember
this was their agenda and now they have
to run away from their own agenda joy
behar did the same thing she blamed
trump for rising crime
yes probably it was the president who
was calling for law and order
the same president you were screaming at
screaming at
for suggesting perhaps we might use the
insurrection act quell riots in most of
america's major cities
the same president you were yelling at
for putting federal troops in place
or federal officers rather in places
like portland to protect federal
property
probably it was him yes joy it wasn't
you it was him
every president since clinton inherited
a basically a declining
crime rate and then continue it
continued to decline
until trump came along because trump
recited over the greatest crime rise
in modern american history the murder
rate shot up 26 percent
and mass shootings have spiked hate
crimes spiked more than 20 percent
during his presidency
now i don't want to lay the whole thing
at his feet but he did create four years
normalizing crime
four years normalizing crime what in the
actual
f like seriously who's got two thumbs
and wants you to like and subscribe